I'm telling you right now if I don't
trust a youth condom with a regular
human woman
you'll be goddamned if I just give it to
a homeless lady as like hey don't do
anything weird with it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome this
next comic the host of the punch-drunk
sports podcast give it up
Midori Shapiro everybody thank you
everybody thank you very much all right
this story is what my friend said with
the gayest thing that's ever happened to
him I whatever I don't really like that
kind of talk but whatever so it starts I
was having sex with a girl and I was
using a woman and that's one of those
things where feminists are right like
yes absolutely I was a grown person and
I used a condom for once
I know you guys feel when you use a
condom I feel like a champion for like
the rest of the month I'm always like
not part of the problems it's one time
and if you wear a condom that means you
don't have to work on them the next nine
times it cancels out it cancels out
that's just how it works that's what
science you guys if you don't really
disagree you don't know science it's
like when you have a salad for lunch you
have a whole pizza for dinner
so do i what do you guys do you're done
having sex with economy what do you do
soon as you're finished
what pull her off hey Dad yeah that's a
number one thing you're absolutely right
like I'm finished now you should leave
leave my dick it's like done you feel
it's shrinking inside of you so you want
to pull out like it'll come out on his
own that's why you know winter is over
make it smaller
great answer man
yeah you pull up yeah and then you take
the condom off and you guys put the
cottonmouth you got to throw it away
well yeah you got it first of all you
got to pull it off because at some point
you lay there for like a minute or two
you know before you pull it off you
don't be like if I can take this
you know like grenade get it out of here
but like she's lying on your shoulders I
and you realized you're like once your
dick is completely limp like this isn't
sexual anymore and you realize like
you've just been basting in June your
dick is like a haagen-dazs dip cone of
demon yeah it's got like a reverse
Benjamin Button or something it's gonna
prune up like you're in the shower too
long you know normally my dick legs got
progeria so you got to take it off and a
lot of people will get up and throw the
condom out which that's cool if you've
got the energy I hard I don't have
that kind of energy so uh yeah I go for
it if you're going to go for it so I'll
take the condom all and I'll just throw
it by the side of the bed or any because
ever do that move the classic you've
never done that
Oh cuz you're black why people don't use
condoms that's why like what I don't
even understand this whole story what
are you talking about what you have to
explain to me why would you advance them
real estate when you're talking to this
girl yeah deep double-height excited
about you get at the next morning that's
what I was going to do I'll tie it off
you don't like just drop it then I'll
leak out you're gonna like tie it off
especially we got dogs if you got dogs
you gotta tie that off they'll go for it
dogs will go for it they don't know
they're known off sexuality they just
know protein legend some protein
yeah a daughter like oppa you can yell
it up like stop talking be like I think
you're wrong here why would I not eat
why'd you cover in protein if you want
me to eat it so yeah for sure tie it off
and uh the morning came and I got to
throw it away I don't I was going to
flush I don't like it throw away condoms
at women's places because like part of
me worries I think this might be crazy
but like yeah well hold on it's not
completely crazy if you all kind of know
what I'm about to say right yeah it's
not completely off the wall not that
she's gonna yeah undo the condom and
then put it up there and screw
in and have a baby the
old-fashioned way through traffic yeah
so I was like Arnold flushing the toilet
but then I got to a toilet that's a
flush it and it twists it looks like for
sure handle it
like I don't be here for two hours you
know
sounds like talking I'll just I'll just
go outside I'll throw it out outside in
the dumpster yeah so I'm going down
there steps or apartment building
holding this used condom use not a lock
on I'm hoping not to pass any of our
neighbors like good morning mrs. Johnson
enjoy Church worried about this and then
I got outside I was about to throw it
out and then uh there was a homeless
lady in the dumpster yeah homeless woman
just rooting around in there I guess
that's for sure not a lady but uh yeah
it's a homeless woman looking for I
don't know her meal or whatever I don't
know what they do in there and I'm
telling you right now if I don't trust a
youth condom with a regular human woman
you'll be goddamned if I just give it to
a homeless lady and she's like hey don't
do anything weird with this I mean that
is a cash win for a homeless person that
is child support for the rest of her
life
that is the loan if she'd be crazy not
to try it really she recreates not at
all I myself like that's the seed of a
man with a job
she'd be like you ever hear that you
ever hear that a story about like God
sending a like the guy drowning because
anybody religious here you know what I'm
talking about
amen oh yeah lady hell yeah we have all
men but that's okay and what she's
saying yeah where the man was drowning
and he prayed to God to save him and
then him like the ocean and then a
rowboat came by you know this one and
then he's like rowboat guys like hey get
in he goes no no God's gonna save me
beat it and the robotoid look right and
then uh later like a bigger boat came by
he's like get in and he's like no
talking God's gonna save me get out of
here
probably didn't curse as much as I have
but uh and then a giant ship came by and
like get in you're gonna drown he goes
no God is going to save me and then he
left and then the guy just
drowned he just sauntered round and he
got the heaven and he's like God why did
you save me and gods like what are you
talking about I sent a rowboat and a
medium sized ship and a big ship for you
so that's this homeless lady she got to
heaven
you're like how come you never gave me a
hand up but gods like I gave you a
vial a demon of a man with a
home what else you need me to do put
some of it in now and save the other
half but when you're ovulating so I was
like I can't throw at the dumpster and I
was like well what am I supposed to do
with this condom so I was like it
I'll just I'll just take it home and
I'll throw it out when I get home yeah I
was frustrating not to be able to deal
with a stupid condom so I get in my car
I put it in a little decide trashcan of
the car you know you know that's what
it's for it's more like owner's manuals
or math but nobody uses that it's but
when you're done with the Cheetos bag
like what am I so I put it in there and
I started driving home and I passed on
the way home I passed my friend at the
bus stop Jason Tebow yeah my co-host I'm
a punch truck podcast and I pulled over
like what are you doing he's like well
I'm going to work and I was like well
it man get in and I'll give you a
ride he's like really the kill I'm in a
great mood absolutely
I don't mind and so we start driving it
gets the research everything goes uh
goes where you coming from my in such a
good mood and okay now right here I
probably could just told them but I
thought like show him you know
it's a way richer way of telling a story
like a great school didn't have tell
they had showing home so he was like
where you're coming from right so then I
just reached in to the little trash can
i got i got the knot in the condom like
right between my thumb and my forefinger
i just kind of fell for it and then I
grabbed it and then and then I hit him
in the face with it yeah I came around
now I didn't want look this way because
I might hit me you know who they went
around it was going too fast and things
Suresh when I was coming around like it
got wider and then I hit him like coming
forward it made like a like a that kind
of sound like a big slap I remember his
seatbelt locked I remember that yeah I
did hit it and then the thing was just
dangling there and he he was not happy
about it
he was pretty upset I've definitely seen
him happier
yeah he was mad he's hurst yelling go
did you just hit me with the full condom
and i was like i mean i don't know about
full just a little bottom part is full
if that's a full condom you have a very
positive way of looking at the world
she was mad he goes that's the gayest
thing that's ever happened to me and I
don't say that not to the homophobia or
anything he was using in the right
context it used to be a homosexual and
I'm like it wasn't gay it wasn't
homosexual if you ask me suggest me I
didn't hit him with the inside of the
condom if I turned it inside out sure
that's the part that had my dick in it
you know and where all the Jesus stuff
was I hit him with the outside of the
condom that came straight from touching
a vagina it got all up in the vagina and
then hit him across the face if anything
it's the most heterosexual thing that's
ever happened to it yeah it's been 12
years he still does not see it my way
all right I'm done thank you very much
everybody
[Applause]